It's always sad to watch your favorite character
shuffle off this mortal coil.
But it's even worse for the actors involved,
who often have to film these emotionally difficult
scenes over and over again.
It's no wonder, then, that actors often try
to lighten the mood by goofing off right as
their character is kicking the bucket.
Here's a look at some unexpected bloopers
during death scenes.
Inglourious Basterds
Sally Menke was an Academy Award-nominated
film editor who worked on nearly all of Quentin
Tarantino's films until she passed away in
2010.
While working with Menke, actors and crew
members on Tarantino films would leave friendly
messages for her while shooting — which
she'd discover months later in the editing
bay, like this bit from Inglorious Basterds
actor Til Schweiger.
"Sally!
I am not dead!
I just pretended.
Now I'm gonna go after him and I'm going to
kick his f---ing Nazi b---s, okay?"
Dracula: Dead and Loving It
Mel Brooks virtually created the movie parody
genre, making full-length parodies of entire
film genres like Blazing Saddles, Spaceballs,
and Dracula: Dead and Loving It.
In one scene, a pair of vampire hunters played
by Brooks and Steven Weber needed to stake
a vampire named Lucy.
Weber barely held it together as the scene
plays out a little more… vigorously than
he expected.
"Ohhhh my God!"
The Avengers
All true fanboys and fangirls shed a tear
at the shocking loss of SHIELD agent Phil
Coulsen in Marvel's blockbuster The Avengers.
But nobody took it quite as hard as Cobie
Smulders, whose agent Maria Hill simply expressed
what every one of us was feeling in that dreadful
moment.
"Coulsen!
Nooooo!
God!
You were the greatest man I ever knew!"
And she didn't stop there.
"You will be avenged!
You will be avenged!
I will get The Avengers, and you will be avenged,
Coulsen!"
Jaws
As grizzled old Quint in Jaws, Robert Shaw
got to have a spectacular, gruesome, and memorable
farewell.
The cast and crew probably had no idea the
scene would go down in the annals of movie
history, because to Shaw it was downright
hilarious...thanks to just a little too much
fake blood.
Calling Mel Brooks!
[Groaning then laughter]
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2
Making movies is tough work, with shooting
days regularly lasting more than 14 hours
as crews prepare sets, lighting, props, and
practical effects rigs.
That means a lot of tired actors, as Michael
Rooker proved in this scene from Guardians
of the Galaxy volume 2.
Since he was playing the deceased Yondu, all
he had to do was lie there while his co-stars
delivered a heartfelt eulogy over his body,
but it turned out to be… just a little too
comfortable.
"Sometimes it's right there by your side all
along and you don't even know it."
[Snoring]
Even Drax couldn't wake him!
Merlin
Eoin Macken portrayed Sir Gwaine on the long-running
British series Merlin — right up until the
character was laid low by treachery.
The once mighty Gwaine expired in the arms
of his friend Percival, played by Tom Hopper,
while sadly lamenting his failure to stop
the bad guys.
Or at least, it should have been sad, but
Hopper apparently took it a little differently.
[Laughter]
The Interview
In Seth Rogen and James Franco's controversial
2014 comedy The Interview, the duo played
an American talk show producer and host sent
to North Korea on a mission to assassinate
the nation's leader, Kim Jong Un.
Along the way, Rogen's character got into
a fight to the finish with a North Korean
agent.
But as this blooper shows, the two actors
weren't exactly treating it like a moment
where life hangs in the balance.
"Slow push!"
[Screaming]
"Sorry!"
Game of Thrones
When Jon Snow was assassinated on Game of
Thrones by his own men at the end of season
5, it was one of the most shocking moments
ever on the HBO fantasy series.
So would the red witch be able to bring him
back to life during season 6?
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!